Hello, my name is Reto Meier,
and welcome to this week in
Android development on Monday,
August 12, 2013.
Last week saw designers in the
Bay Area come together to talk
about designing for Android
surprising the few
cyberneticists who came along
expecting to design an android
the size and shape of
San Francisco Bay.
The Google Play games services
team were at it once again
with another episode of Game On
where Todd and Bruno talked
cloud save.
And J-F showed us how to detect
overdraw using the
hierarchy viewer.
Our design advocates introduced
design bytes with
Nick demonstrating responsive
design and Roman donning a
darker, yet still
color-coordinated ensemble, to
explain how you can flatten
existing icons using Photoshop.
Chet taught us some cartoon
animation techniques while
remaining oblivious to the
logo-shirt coordination
requirements.
And [INAUDIBLE]
Ankur and J-F went backstage
once more to answer questions
on Ankur's series of DevBytes
on making apps beautiful.
And this week, J-F will be
talking about optimizing
layouts with hierarchy viewer
and opening the Australian top
order for the fifth
Ashes Test.
And tune in for a new face in
dev bytes with a new clip on
image pixelization.
If you're in Europe, now would
be a great time to plan a
vacation with Dan Galpin heading
up the games invasion,
starting with a stop at the
Google Developer group meet up
in London on the 15th.
That's all for this week
in Android development.
Be sure to check out this week's
dev and design bytes,
because it just won't
do without you.